more details are emerging about how
actress Lorie Laughlin and her husband
allegedly bribed their daughter's way
into USC on Friday attorneys for 15
parents accused in the college
admissions scandal were back in courts
earlier this week the prosecution made
public more than 500 pages of documents
never released before as Carter Evans
reports they include emails phone call
logs even bank checks that could send
the parents to jail Lori Lachlan and
Massimo Chia newly have long argued they
did nothing wrong when they paid five
hundred thousand dollars to get their
daughters into the University of
Southern California suggesting they were
just making donations to the school
after the couple's daughter's
application was accepted newly released
emails show Rick singer the mastermind
behind the alleged scam told gia newly
to send a $50,000 check to USC and the
rest of the 200 thousand will be paid to
our foundation the USC check was made
out to Donna heinel a senior athletic
director at the time the emails also
reveal the lengths gia newly and Lachlan
went to to get their youngest daughter
admitted as a recruit to the crew team
even though she didn't grow
competitively singer emailed the couple
saying it would help to get a picture of
her on a rowing machine in workout
clothes like a real athlete gia newly
responded fantastic we'll get all CBS
legal analyst Ricky Kleman the notes
clearly show that they were in this game
as far as it would take them I'm legally
not allowed to speak on anything going
on right now
their daughter YouTube star olivia jade
won't comment but last month resurfaced
online the new court documents show the
high school she and her sister attended
had raised a red flag alerting us see
the girls may not be rowers the
administrator USC assigned to
investigate Donna heinel the same
athletic director who allegedly cashed G
a new least 50 thousand dollar check
the problem is the stuff that you put in
email comes back to haunt you and in
their case they just put too much in
writing but it could also hurt Lorrie
Lachlan because the couple fought to
share the same lawyers and have their
case tried to
together right now the way it looks if
they go in with the same lawyer and they
put forth the united front if he goes
down she is going down for CBS this
morning Saturday Carter Evans Los
Angeles
you